I just like to thank herbal discounted
prices to their business breakfast it's
been a great morning to do a
presentation to all the guests and
really interactive we very much
appreciate it and Kobes here today the
Rochford business breakfast to launch
the partnership want-want business
safari service we're delighted to be
working partnership District Council to
even initiate some important advice
service small businesses here the area
yes traditionally cog has been
delivering business advice and two
priests are established and every other
business in between we've said that
she's already said we're very happy to
be announcing our partnership with Roger
District Council to the same service
that we've been to the right now we're
in the county in profit so it's open to
all shapes and sizes we provide three
fully funded hour-long sessions to
anyone who'd like to get in touch with
us so practice is planning marketing
finance strategy whatever it might be so
it's really great valuable service to
most most businesses and that money will
get involved and get in touch if they
would like to speak to us about it for
me to do with their business
you